music and water will be the last thing
to leave desert because we can't live
without water or music and I love just
how many accolades and how many awards
you have in the house usually the same
way when you've been around lady or
seventy years man
what was your where would you start
where what when did you find that you
had this love no I wanted to be a
gangster I was from Chicago and here it
is not lost my mother when I was seven
right and I was a street rat man I saw
dead bodies and tommy guns and stogies
and piles of money mmm my daddy worked
for gangsters the most notorious triple
o Jesus and in America's history right
Jones was I'm doing a movie on it and he
built their homes but these Scouts were
rough man they had the numbers racket
and a five and dime stores and they they
made a hundred and forty million dollars
in 1941 the poem freaked he wasn't ready
but that's smart
yeah and he drowned him out of Chicago
from Mexico painting and then after a
while he made a deal with him to cool
off his hit man he seen him down there
for three months to cool off in Iraq you
know when I was seven the leader of the
gang Eddie Jones his daughter wanted me
to give her a haircut she was five I'd
cut all the hair off my dolly gonna kick
my ass man yeah he's been a friend all
these years I'm doing a movie on his
life you know I thought they didn't play
anything but younger young black kids
don't know who these people are man do
you know who Paul Williams is no I'm
saying he built the Beverly Hills Hotel
he built sex with Alan Rubin Airport
Sinatra Lucille Ball the biggest
architect in the history of LA in the
thirties he had to learn how to write
upside down because he wasn't allowed to
sit like this white clients I know daddy
used to come see them every year okay
but you should know about these people
yeah greatest architects that ever lived
that's insane that is nice it gives you
hope when you see it's already happened
you know you don't have to come up with
it yourself it's crazy just I can only
imagine how it was being a black
creative back then because even right
now there's all this this sense of
oppression that we get as black
creatives and exactly exactly as he kind
of thirties forties fifties of census
data and that's I'm saying we went to
Vegas with Sinatra when I went in the
Achilles mr. brother said Frank wants to
see over into the slot machines and he
had basis old ban because Vegas in 64
was so racist Lena Horne and Belafonte
were working in the big room for $17,000
in a week they were not allowed in the
casino they had the heat in the kitchen
sing and go to a black hotel across town
so Frank said they don't have no more
that so we came in he had 18 goombas
mafia guys to put with each one of us
and he stopped the racism in one year
for some nitro came for Basie Sammy
myself and bassist man and stuffing and
Kool and the gang he's a tough guy he's
left me that ring that's awesome
speaking of that just cuz my family we
grew up off of the ways those are just
one the ways and that something that
inspired me is as an african-american
and throughout musical theater that's
where were you born I was born in 1998
oh please
my mom introduced me to their ways and
told me that this is the musical that I
need to learn and that I needed to study
because of her infatuation with the fact
that a predominantly old wore all black
cast you know they were pissed off about
it so I was on the board then and they
said how dare they make a black version
of that white classic and they portrayed
the old one the next Sunday at the
academy because they were really pissed
off that we value did we did it you know
and my Oscar was taken from me on that
that's taken from me man watching that
movie as a child young
I mean I still have my child it's
something that did changed my perception
on just musical theater for me that's
that's one of the reasons that I have
fell in love with it and like after
seeing them with the movie I actually
joined like our musical theater
department in my high school and I
auditioned for my first musical which
was healing dolly and I got a true
blonde yeah well I made uh she was June
on 97 it's been seven decades man yeah I
think about that all the time
that's this guy Julian be with me less
you about come back to said if you never
go away you're on to make a comeback
there's a never leave all right
the growers you go you don't have to go
away that's right
how was it working on there with Michael
I meant working on everything is a dream
all right it's a it's a gift from God it
is hey this is hard man yeah we went
through eight hundred songs to get nine
for my furlough Batcave and then after
we get the nine always sit down in the
corner drop the ego and say what are the
four weakest songs of these nine mm-hmm
relatively right you have to be very
honest about that and I took out some
big songs Mike some bellroad carousel
captors had Flashdance you know yeah and
total sent me some songs wasn't really
crazy about the songs they sent but I
left the bride and I were at home we
left the tape on and after about 20
minutes we heard doo doo doo boo didn't
have lyrics on it and I said that's it I
was looking for harmonic kaleidoscope
you know I was looking for that to
follow the mantra of Billie Jean were
just three chords in it yeah and
well good-bye miles everybody did it man
I'm so happy it's crazy just the songs
to the secret man yeah the singers the
messenger the songs of the secret path a
great song can make the worst thing in
the world a star mm-hmm and a bad song
can't be saved by the three greatest
singers in the world and I learned that
50 years ago thing yeah well it's just
good to know though
yeah and all the songs are at random
series of the messenger it's also about
how the song makes you feel well course
it is right of course it is but it ain't
new yeah I've been doing it a long time
man but those early brothers Brahms Bach
Beethoven they took up all the good [ __ ]
man they used the ball good know right
hey I was he working with Oprah fine
just like working with another musician
mm-hmm outside I've had to go to a court
case for Michael baby he was accused of
plagiarism on or not the girl was mine
and had to walk to get the coffee since
the plane for me to go on there to go to
court and I couldn't sleep
so I kept turning on TV and I kept
seeing this woman on that I said damn if
she can if she can act that's that's
silly I mean that's Sophia yeah and I
finally found out her name from a friend
of mine after three days when I sent the
tapes to Spielberg and she didn't tell
suitable acting testing yeah you take
two lines from the script and they had
they had lived for 40 minutes
mm-hmm and what would kill that I got it
I got it on tape down as there's no joke
she killed as you said you would know
from that location and she killed it man
yes or no right and Whoopi was working
in the streets of San Francisco because
at that time Stephen wanted to use that
Oh Ross no
let's get some purple people right we
did all right and we got 11 Oscar
nominations hey Stephen wasn't even
nominated how'd it happen that feels as
good as it gets me 11 nominations and we
couldn't win because he wasn't nominated
they were jealous of him yeah so he
asked me to be his date to go to the
Directors Guild and 250 guys at the
academy scared to death of him he was
frightened of you know because he was so
good even Lucas or no they
revolutionized movies yeah I don't know
we went to the Directors Guild 7800
directors said right next to Sydney
[ __ ] you know I'd done his first
movie yeah and he had out of Africa
which killed us you know yeah and they
couldn't vote for us cuz Stephen wasn't
nominated you know what the director you
get eight not living nominations and
directors not and there's something
wrong yeah but we've changed all the
rules after that asking for the songs so
Isaac Hayes could win so the Beatles um
so French could win I never knew it
would go as far as it's hard out here
for Penn 6 mafia yeah but we changed all
those rules are not all right officers
if we all should hip hop into the
ministry and his principal and all that
stuff
I know isoprene the house with Dell oh
cool yeah he was engaged my daughter too
it's crazy
fresh Francis asbestos thank you oh
that's Tiffany I was Cartier Cartier
yeah but as a gigolo just Middleton uh I
decided I liked my mom was definitely
not a fan why I see it shouldn't
election Burgess seems like why are you
spending all that money on it I was like
because it goes cost a lot a month I
want to stay around this one's probably
7,500 yeah I mean for me I felt like
each one I got was just based off an
accomplished
that kind of garnish great yeah and just
literally uh looking back I mean when I
started writing music I wrote my first
song my senior year in high school which
was 2016 2015 so it was crazy like to
matter yay
and so when I made all these
accomplishments and I said all these
goals for myself and I stopped listening
to a lot of the negativity that I was
getting for one being a creative being
an african-american who wasn't you know
it wasn't afraid of his musicality and
so I told all these people all these
people made them secondly the sunshine
yeah yeah and I told all these people
who doubted me I told them I was like
look a year from now this is where I'm
gonna be but when you put that put that
out into existence it's like okay now
you have to put in the work behind it to
make it true for everything that
happened as fast as it happened to me is
just as definitely it's crazy it's
unreal and so after each accomplishment
you know I got I got myself a couple of
things that I'd look at and I'm like wow
remind you they reminded me it is I mean
walking around you know your house and
looking at the Grammys
it's just crazy because I'm up for I
have five knobs which is insane to think
about and it reminds me seeing all these
accolades and seeing all these awards
that it's reachable it sits in your
reach but it's about if you're going to
put the work and the effort and to make
things that you love and that you truly
believe in so it was super inspiring
just being in here and just seeing
everything that you've worked on and
even that sheet music yeah that's all my
favorite composers here too hmm so star
wars sets out of your smile with Johnny
and then all my friends we all started
together you know Johnny Williams as
strictly drained out of Universal Bernie
Harmon the room although it's called
stuff right from the day we started in
because I want to be a gangster till 11
then I changed to music at 11 when we
broke him in an army and Ray Charles
would not let us do anything would be
loyal to every genre man
it was a bomb it felt natural
Debussy pop music strip music we played
everything then in the 40s in Seattle we
played the white tennis club CL Tennis
Club would like cardigans and play pop
music would cup noobs and everything on
there we go to Washington educational
social club which was the bottle club
that was in the hood and playful rhythm
and blues we did comedy everything we
did everything that dance saying
commonly everything played with
elephants that would Billie Holiday
would Billy Eckstine would Cab Calloway
no we were not afraid to know we could
compete with them at 14 and 15 we can
handle it and so we were a big fish on a
little pond from Seattle so we got to
New York we weren't afraid like the New
York's are afraid that they had a face
Charlie Parker miles and Mingus - no but
it was an amazing journey how many
instruments can you play after I stopped
being a gangster the next day I went to
Robert II concerts in our school I
played sousaphone trouble b-flat
baritone a flat Alto French horn
trombone so we could play in the
marching band with the majorettes
yeah the trumpet in the back so I would
with the major Epps yeah and got the
trumpet that's why I would like to write
for brass because I played all the brass
backwards you know yeah sousaphone -
love it crazy and you know nothing beats
the the process of knowing those
instruments mm-hmm know what a trombone
does and kettle B flats or stuff you
know yeah I mean the range of every
instrument in theory other transpose of
all of them yeah serious serious trouble
there's a lot that comes with it that
people don't really see and I know they
don't know they don't know it's there ya
know but that's what you have to dig it
up yeah and go for it I find that's the
magic if you go to be special yeah and
you have to I don't play any instance
well you learn some sometimes you play
don t know oh come on
and indivisible that i feel i Abhisek
yeah that's all I have interested in
learning how to play guitar and I had to
play piano because for me I feel like it
would make songwriting so much easier it
was my face it was it opens up a door
for you all right let's see know what
music is about now yes it's a trip and
there's only 12 notes man yeah that's it
and basically Asia and Africa uses
pentatonic music which is above five
notes and then there's diatonic you know
which is all we can hear because the
chromatic of the 12 notes you can you
can hear all that you know but you got
to know it yeah you know in the quarter
tones like the Indians to on Arabs yeah
it's heavy
see man and it's different all over the
world and it reflects their civilization
yeah you know how they deal with pain
right that's where the Blues came from
yeah pain and racism and all that stuff
it swords you ought to protect yourself
in them and it's crazy how something
like that just influences music once
once you find out what it was once you
kind of discover and create it it
influences everything
well Africa is all about the difference
between the European music which is
conceptual music and virtuosity
mm-hm and concerts and so forth that's
what the European music is about right
African music is about life force muse
yeah virginity right circumcision rights
and everything else and that's what all
the field hollows came from the make
your life easier a woman of such your
ass you know
you know what blues the same to get over
and hear it's heavy and you know what
music and water will be the last thing
to leave this earth because we can't
live without water or music and even how
long could you go without music I don't
think it's possible I'm saying you
couldn't do more than a day yeah I don't
think you could nobody can live without
music or water music is within
everything
- yeah what is cool for me I feel like
my biggest competition obviously is
myself and I feel like I'm so in my head
about everything and producing is one
thing that I have an interesting but I
feel like I have difficulty jumping all
the way in what for me I mean I feel
like it's a lot of it's hard
remember you can't get an A if you're
afraid of an else yeah you can't do it
I'm sorry yeah and it's about just just
building and for me I never know when to
stop because what she can't deal with
fear man yeah no the only fear I had in
my life was cuz I lost my mother seven
was not being prepared for a great
opportunity and cuz imma be ready for
whatever comes right that's was not for
called me I was 29 you know already I
knew music was for me was the moment I
heard my mom sing because that's where I
got my voice my mom can sing circles
around me or smoothies is from church
yes she grew up to do it whatever you
like yeah tell people you see grew up
off of all that but then she actually
she joined a girl group when she was
around my age and then she joined the
military to support well she'll she's in
the army
really yeah well she she started I want
to say in North Carolina and she went
all over the world I didn't go to
breakfast other than how to break which
is the one out yelling fellow yeah worms
as though yeah that's what Rob talked to
me Raiders here looks like all the worms
so hearing my mom still have this voice
and still singing even though she was in
the army
she still love music and she's saying to
me every single night and that's kind of
where I knew that it was for me because
I felt like it was in my blood just just
seeing her in fact
and how how what does have to deal with
no fear of man yeah got to go all the
way
mm-hmm and give it everything you've got
cause like nothing frustrates me more
than people are saying well that's only
worth 15% of my interests in art that's
all I'm gonna give it right you give it
two hundred percent every time man get
out of the fear zone you know get out of
the free zone
a lot I'm feeling fear here you know
like that all right dive in man with
everything you got and give it to
hundred percent of your soul and we'll
come back twice as full I promise you
yeah
I know I feel like no fear no fear I
can't even say it I feel yeah okay would
come music she's gotta do it bring it
out man if the past is there I mean if
the tribe is there and the more you
learn about it the less fear you have
because you know what everybody's done
with it you know you know that
Adolphe Sax and no and no in belgium in
1760 invented the saxophone was the SI
XE when all these classical guys had
played it was with Ravel's Bolero almost
seems like like little historical
movements that development them and then
impacts life yeah yeah guys like today
it's like disco man basically was going
forward to the floor man in 1930s and
70% of hip-hop slang comes from from
jazz man they think that the breakdance
came from the Bronx man you lost
[ __ ] a cantata revel in Brazil and
some martial arts Bennett now if you
look over you know if they don't know
that they can happen in Bronx it's
[ __ ] keep it on you know because
once you acknowledge who your
predecessors were man it opens up your
mind keeps you from being all right you
know narrow-minded exactly
they'll keep that mind open because
there's so much that comes with yes sir
and you'll serve us a lifestyle the
bebop thing was almost like a political
revolution man everything in it man
even the mixed marriages was stuff like
that all this stuff was part of a
revolution mm-hmm bottom line Kali is
every time you approach your creativity
you have to do that with humility and
your success with grace right well God
walks out of the room
mm-hmm I just wonder what attitude like
I got it no one reckon I'm better than
everybody else man yeah that's not
that's not the way this in that you know
how to do military all right your builds
in grace one kid said that oh that's hot
I mean my mom put that into your
principles together because the
principles goal with your your musical
training yes it's about I mean
everything we all have a purpose is what
we're doing it for yes that's right but
passionately it's about his going all
the way
what son are you having acquaintance
okay what they have even later when we
look at my daughter's the knife yeah
it's a good son yeah I love being
acquaintance I mean I'll write the
Holyrood pledges I think he's gotta love
it metal yeah exactly
your sign has more effect on you than
your parents do right you know your
ascendant and rising and Oh actually I'd
forget that's your best friend
and I forgot my ass yeah you know that's
your best friend mine is Leo mm-hmm and
my that's my scented my descendant is
Scorpio all right that's crazy
that's things I definitely need to know
that's true that's who you are man I
know I was just it was crazy because I
was I was checking my horoscope I was
checking for Aquarius and I just saw so
much that was just so relative to me
that and just taste my perception and
just how I thought about everything that
that's something that I really wanted
kind of research and good background
yeah no not so amazing him your signs I
studied astronomy 27 years with John
the astronaut then I learned so much
from him I can tell you he was he looked
like he's three thousand years old but
now you taught me so much you tell my
son says there's no some sense man yeah
up here I see it because it comes up in
the West these fella
Sibbi that's crazy oh yeah I know the
view that you have is ridiculous you see
everything exact we've designed the
house so you can't miss it
yeah how did it affect your outlook
living or visiting all these different
countries on life well the feeling of
going that every country in the world
and feeling home there yeah is the
greatest feeling in the world you know
all the food you know the language man
like mama I'm just sharing which is
Gerald Stockholm is called should
bolometer Tata smooth it's all the same
stuff man old age water in Brazil but
econo or
macumba that's the same stuff now and
when should get the soul of each country
yeah becomes yours that's how I feel
about ya everywhere everywhere in the
world I loved going to Australia New
Zealand I feel like I've they made me a
Maori chief yeah yeah I got a jade
bracelet Oh like white light broke you
know what everything got a lot of
gangsters newsela the other side
nah man man is Hell's Angels of 6,000
gangsters only five thousand cops
history orchestras a trip you know yeah
it's kind but it you learn that at the
same time you know whatever stuff you
because it goes with the language and
everything else everything we do here is
like three or four hundred years a man
what should go to Rome and we go to a
five-star restaurant we eat of pasta
ragout which I cook in Africa chopped
carrot surgery and it's expensive as
hell man that five-star restaurant but
you go to the airport and the same dish
which is one tenth of the price you
can't make it any better they've been
doing it for four thousand years yeah
and all the comforts are like that yeah
except us and
and she just drinks back away I'm super
happy
I saw the sheet music for we are the
world I thought that was super most
people's name on it yeah and it the
awesome thing about that is just that's
such a song that impacted my upbringing
and little family and my mom that's a
song we wouldn't have done a dip for if
Bob Geldof and Bonnell hadn't done Live
Aid and adults understood they enjoyed
it we ain't doing nothing nice to it as
they wanted to go on the road I said no
way to take all the maniacs on the road
we do a record yeah was it difficult
getting everybody in there and teaching
them all I've already done it with Donna
Summer that's why they called me
hey anyone crazy enough to deal with all
them people right yeah
we only state of independence we had
Stevie my Lionel Van Dyle all painting
yes exciting
[Music]
for me the way that I start songs is is
based off of I'll start with the melody
so then what else yeah exactly so when
you start this is the King Balak we yeah
when you start off with the melody
that's God for us yeah Noli is God's
voice then you put two how k how does
how did how do these sounds how do these
make me feel what do I feel when I when
I hear it then that's when you put the
words in and I feel like for me the
words it's not necessarily the most
difficult part because it comes natural
I mean I feel like a song should never
be forced if you don't feel it when it's
there then start a new idea and then
keep going I feel like a lot of things I
feel like a lot of people probably think
that you have to keep trying and keep
trying with the same song until it's
whatever it's like I mean I don't ever
want to sing a song I'm not in love with
you what I don't ever want to sing a
song I'm not involved
you should write a little thing every
song you're right you should want to
sing exactly because I mean once you
created it's there for it forever even
past life it's there so why am I gonna
create a song that I know that I'm gonna
have to sing into the day that my heart
stops beating why would I want to create
a song that that I hate Oh nobody wants
to know everybody wants the best you
know but you have to realize what you're
gonna put into it to make it the best
man you have to put a lot of work a lot
of work you know but that's what it
takes and but in the moment that the
work is just it doesn't even necessarily
feel like work because his passion it's
passing you know we're still in the same
thing yeah my least favorite number is
number two six and eleven you everybody
by the time I got a top six record or
top eleven record and if I'm number two
I won't be number one all right the hell
with number two it's amazing journey go
brother you're gonna see thank you
you're 19 now yes
she visibly and I learned very early
when to shut up and remember why God
gave us two ears and one mouth you know
why I supposed to listen twice as much
as you talk all right now truly one
mouth shut the [ __ ] up listen I'm
serious yeah and you enjoyed you know
and now I'm enjoying everything right
now
oh yes so much yeah just roll with it
well and that music and girls film oh
please you know Frank was always trying
to hook me up with Marilyn Monroe you
know but I like made me Van Doren better
oh you know maybe then during this
googling so you don't play there big
melon look like Mike Tyson
Aziz pine noun to see left a message for
me she said I'll be on the chartreuse
convertible four blocks from here don't
make me wait Paris yeah I appreciate you
for allowing me to do you take me I
don't know but they did it to me man I
mean I had all the guys around the Kings
like Ellington said may you be the one
to be categorized American music well I
mean they trusted me man and handed me
responsibilities man I'm not lived up to
it yeah Boop Double Down all right let
us go from here well I believe humility
and grace that's something like you felt
really important
[Music]
you